Mariah Carey opens up about being  honored by GLAAD and dishes new wedding  details  it feels great I want to kind of  dedicate this to everyone here for being  Mike how much I appreciate everybody  here the singer was honored with the  ally award at the GLAAD Media Awards in  New York City Saturday night where she  showed off her creativity in her  acceptance speech so we got Elle  legendary G gorgeous B beautiful all of  you beautiful people T tantalizing and  even Q for quality equally adorable this  shout out she gave her son I wish all of  you love peace harmony and as my  five-year-old son rocky likes to say  boobies and bucks  Mariah looked radiant on the red carpet  posing for photos with her fiance  billionaire businessman James Packer  backstage the superstar got candid with  et confirming her twins Moroccan and  Monroe will play a role in her upcoming  nuptials my kids will always be with me  and at these Affairs miss Monroe has her  own dress